a rainbow appearing over the ballpark
after heavy rains fell just prior to
game time tonight he's one and three and
guess what that one win came against
these tigers back on june 28th where he
went five innings
slowed it down and struck him out just
throws him
with a change up your newest 20-22 tiger
jonathan scope signed to a two-year
extension a ground ball up the middle
and through for a base hit for jonathan
scope the hitting streak now it's seven
games that indian lineup will be facing
left-hander tyler alexander who's making
his 31st appearance and seventh start of
the 2021 season strikes out straw
logos everywhere
candelario first pitch swinging
launching one to deep left center field
and off the wall
a leadoff double for jamer candelario
here on the second
haters are taking advantage of the
strike thrown by eli morgan gets that
fastball down out over the middle of the
plate jamer doesn't try to pull it
just shoots it into the left center eli
morgan knew it right away just put his
head down like oh no
they kept it in the ballpark but a good
lead off double good way to start the
second inning here for the tigers here's
eric haas
up the middle
nice play by clement he saved a run
there
it's an infield single for eric haas and
detroit has runners at the corners
but he puts it in play here shallow
center this is going to be trouble straw
with a sliding catch and the runners
cannot advance
candelario got caught he wasn't sure
what was going to happen and by the time
he saw straw go into his slide he went
back to third but no chance to tag up
and score
the 1-1
fly ball right center field mercado's
under it
zach short gets the job done
he brings in jamer candelario for the
tigers first run of the night and it's
one nothing detroit the one two to reyes
sits him down looking second strike out
of the night for tyler alexander akeel
badu in center field tonight way out in
front another great pitch by eli morgan
he struck him out looking with a
changeup in the first inning he got him
to go fish for it here in the third
infield single first time up first pitch
here a shot past uh diving rosario into
left center up on the ball as ramirez of
left fielder miguel will stop at second
two good swings for the one time indians
farmhand eric haas no satisfaction there
being two for two here in cleveland
here's the 1-0
swung on ground ball to short rosario
the short way to second in time for the
force side retired no damage done
in the air shallow center a diving
attempt by mile straw that couldn't get
there
here's the throw to second by big harold
not in time and victor reyes with a lead
off bloop double i'll tell you what this
guy he's he's got good hands on the
inside even though that ball got in on
him he fought it off he still found a
way to get enough of it now to the top
of the order and akeel badu sends one to
left center and that's in for a base hit
victor reyes will try and score
straw's throw is off fine
and badou will hustle all the way to
second take a long turn there he drives
in the second run of the night for
detroit it's two nothing
now the o2
foul tipped into the glove of haas
went away in the fifth third strikeout
of the night for tyler alexander
now to 1-2
he struck him now back to back
who's single twice the next delivery
it swung on foul tipped into the glove
of ramos strikeout number three
between third and short backhanded by
zach short what a throw but big ernie
beats it out
for a one-out single
hustling down the line clement
now miles straw back to the top of the
order he's over two tonight
trying to shoot it the other way that
will get down for a base hit and ernie
clement stops at second so miles straw
follows him
with a base knock and the indians have
back-to-back hits for the first time
tonight
and michael fulmer is coming on former
four and four in 29 appearances two on
one out
a little slow roller this is going to be
an infield hit and the bases are loaded
well that couldn't have worked out any
better two pitch
and a one hopper to the second baseman
castro
and former pulls the rabbit out of the
hat the indians leave them loaded
through six two-nothing detroit
mercano shoots one through the right
side and the indians have a one-out
single
so now they'll bring the tiger under the
plate tops one up the third line
candelario will have no play and the
buffalo stampedes into first second
consecutive inning the indians have hit
a little dribbler to third for an
infield single
ball four and the bases are loaded for
the second inning in a row
albeit with two outs and here comes aj
hinch he is not gonna
give funkhouser an opportunity to get
out of this mess that he created
righty-righty match-up with the bases
loaded and two down here it is
on the ground of first
scope wins the race to the bag and
cleveland
in back-to-back innings leaves them
loaded now the 2-2
jammed him that's a pop-up behind first
it's going to drop another multi-hit
game for jonathan skope osman fouled out
in the first has popped up the third and
popped up the short
rocketed to right field
mercado leaps up makes a great catch one
throw back to first double play
[Applause]
outstanding d by oscar mercado
as soon as he made the leaping catch he
saw
that scope was making a beeline for a
second and he put his foot in the ground
and fired a strike to first base yeah he
thought it was over his head
and he kept going and he didn't look
back and once he made the catch
there was no turning back had it easy
nice play it just wasn't high enough
gregory soto who has been very good for
the tigers high fly ball deep left field
that is going and gone to souvenir city
it's a one-run game
wilson ramos
how do you do soto's got to get ahmed
rosario he sits him down
and saves the day 2-1 the final gregory
soto comes on and slams the door in
cleveland's face here in the ninth
you